[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
116e voyage à travers les provinces le
général de gaulle avait choisi le quercy
et le limousin c'est d'avoir figeac qui
l'a accueilli avec cette chaleur humaine
qui est l'une des vertus de cette
vieille province
le général de gaulle devait s'arrêter
ensuite à un radeau qui fut en 1944 le
théâtre de l'un des plus sauvages
épisode de la retraite allemand le monde
entier connaît depuis le nom de radoub
re dont les murs ruiné au 10 le drame
[Musique]
à limoges le président largement
applaudi devait reprendre des thèmes
essentiels de la position de la france
l'alliance atlantique at il dit est
nécessaire au monde libre mais dans
cette alliance elle veut être la france
à voir sa volonté sa personnalité son
âme et sa politique elle a d'ailleurs
une tâche pratique à laquelle elle
s'applique cette tâche c'est la
construction de l'europe
[Musique]
transporter la veille au palais de
justice l'ex général salan répond devant
le tribunal militaire de tous les crimes
de l'oas un service d'ordre massif
garder les abords du prétoire où les
reporters n'ont pu apercevoir l'accusé
on ne s'étonnera donc pas de nous voir
dans les couloirs que ses défenseurs au
milieu desquelles m tixier vignancour
on verra à la barre la maréchal de
lattre de tassigny et des témoins
politique monsieur léon delbecque jean
marie le pen françois mitterrand le plus
retentissant
le plus douloureux aussi des procès
d'aujourd'hui
[Musique]
bientôt la fête des mères selon une
tradition maintenant établie petits et
grands célébreront cette fête que
magnifier un monument peut être unique
dans tous les foyers la grande
conspiration annuel de la reconnaissance
s'est nouée
[Musique]
et dans la rue même la proche de la fête
des mères a déclenché une vaste
offensive d'affiche et de pavois
[Musique]
c'est l'heure où les tirelires se casse
ou les économies accumulées vont servir
pour le bonheur des uns est aussi le
plaisir des autres c'est l'heure des
cadeaux et quand on voit ton d'avenir
devant soi on a bien le droit
d'atteindre même une pluie de millions
ceux de la loterie nationale
dans les écoles on prépare la surprise
cette oeuvre d'art innocent l'on a mis
son coeur et sa reconnaissance avec sa
joie la fête des mères
[Musique]
le frein n'est pas ce qu'un vin peuple
pense c'est ce qu'une exposition
démontre actuellement à paris grâce au
froid aux foires difficiel 100 ans la
chirurgie a réussi récemment un miracle
l'opération en hypothermie profonde
coeur et activité cérébrale arrêter
toute vie suspendue les banques du sang
qui ont permis de sauver des centaines
de milliers de vies doivent leur
existence aux techniques du froid et
c'est encore au froid qu'on doit de
pouvoir conserver des organes vivant
pour des greffes d'ultérieures
savait-on seulement que c'est un
français ferdinand carrés qui inventa le
premier appareil à fabriquer de la glace
il ya plus de cent ans déjà et que le
premier bateau frigorifique date de 1876
la glace apportant un progrès
considérable
le poisson passe aujourd'hui de la mer à
la table sans quitter son milieu naturel
l'eau de mer transformée en glace 1
million 500 mille tonnes de denrées
périssables les viandes notamment son
véhicule et chaque année par camion
wagon frigorifique
quant au réfrigérateur que possède
actuellement 4 millions de français il
est devenu un ustensile bien banane ce
n'est cependant qu'en 1950 que
l'industrie des réfrigérateurs ménagers
a pris son essor mais avec l allan
une grande usine aéronautique française
a mené son expérience au service de ce
froid domestique éléments de l'ups hier
devenu indispensable aujourd'hui c'est
la nuit écrivait rostand qu'il est bon
de croire à la lumière mais ce n'est pas
seulement l'été qu'on peut apprécier le
froid c'est chaque jour
[Musique]
deux parachutistes sur la région de
haguenau en alsace et manoeuvre bien sûr
mais qui ont réuni d'anciens chefs
départ allemand en crète le général
crowe est un ancien de la 2e db le
général massu pour la première fois des
parachutistes français et allemands
participé côte à côte à un exercice
aéroportée mille paras français béret
rouge et six ans par allemand casquette
grise avec arne matériels ont été ainsi
largué ensemble avec l'appui des
escargots de l'armée de l'air française
et de la luftwaffe un événement dans
l'histoire mouvementée des deux pays
aux usa pendant ce temps on procédait
aux démonstrations spectaculaires d'un
nouveau siège éjectable pour pilote
d'appareil supersonique on a pu
constater par la même occasion que le
fantassin avait également fait de grands
progrès désormais grâce à un réacteur
individuel il pourra agrémenter sa
marche traditionnelle de quelques bons
dans l'atmosphère
or on fantasme américain
[Applaudissements]
dans cet autre entre deux nouveautés
l'industrie automobile vient de
présenter à montlhéry deux modèles de
plus le spécial et le 17 dans les
journalistes spécialisés ont été conviée
à apprécier les qualités en toute
connaissance de cause c'est à dire en en
faisant tout de même l'expérience
du special one ses qualités de silence
grâce à une abbatiale au textile nouveau
et son confort
dupessey pts son confort et son silence
également mais surtout sa réserve
d'adhérence dans tous les cas difficiles
virages et freinage
[Musique]
des accidents n'est que ton inquiétant
aujourd'hui pourquoi ne suis-je pas avec
intérêt tout d'abord nouveau dans la
sécurité
dans une gare de tokyo s'est déroulée
l'un des drames les plus effroyables de
l'histoire ferroviaire le déraillement
d'un premier train a entraîné la
collision de deux autres convois un
fantastique amoncellement d'acier tordus
de wagons entremêlés de corps
déchiquetés c'est le spectacle
hallucinant devant lequel se sont
trouvées les secours
163 morts
385 blessés grièvement pour la plupart
ces chiffres au situe l'ampleur de la
tragédie
[Musique]
la reconnaissance des victimes a donné
lieu à des scènes particulièrement
dramatiques devant la file des cercueils
une foule en larmes cherche à retrouver
un être cher
des filets à la fois misérables est
stupéfiant que le reporter a saisi avec
l'impassibilité du métier mais qui donne
à chacun le goût vrai et si affreusement
humain du drame
[Musique]
après neuf mois de football insipide le
championnat de france est terminée par
un sprint excitant de 90 minutes une
heure et demie avant la fin du
championnat trois équipes ont abordé
presque au coude à coude le dernier
match nîmes légèrement détaché avec un
tout petit point d'avancé suivi de reims
et du racing club de paris botte à botte
des millions de français ont suivi avec
passion cette ultime spectacle suspense
il aurait voulu être partout à la fois
la radio et l ajustement et elle était
partout à la fois
à monaco 15h29 le racing maillot clair
qu'il ne croit pas qu'une option sur le
titre en battant son premier but
pendant ce temps que se passe-t-il à
reims toujours 0 0 devant strasbourg mes
copains numéro 9 pouces affront ses
partenaires
[Applaudissements]
une passe à sauvage qui marque reims
revient à la hauteur du reste
papa et ses partenaires ne s'arrête pas
en si bon chemin il faut à tout prix
créé un smack encore d'autres bus pour
être champion de france ça ne va pas
tarder nouvel exploit de sauvages reims
par la tête du peloton encore 45 minutes
à savoir qui sera champion de france et
on parle d pas ce que font les nîmois
devant le stade français pas grand chose
de bon le score n'a pas changé depuis le
début du match les nîmois un maillot
foncé sont paralysé par le trac
le titre leur échappe à 7 minutes
précises qui bat l'avant centre du stade
français un but qui vaut cher
céline éponyme c'est d'ailleurs fini
également pour le racing puisque à reims
les bus succède au but
[Applaudissements]
là encore quand alan ses partenaires qui
vont pas tarder a ajouté un quatrième
but au tableau d'affichage
des mines le championnat avec beaucoup
d'élégance et c'est un caisse bis qui
signe le dernier but des rémois
[Applaudissements]
les rémois qui sont donc sans confiance
mais regrettons que reims est attendu la
dernière journée du championnat pour
prouver ses qualités
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]